la discussion après engagement de la
procédure accélérée de la proposition de
loi visant à lutter contre les
discriminations par la pratique de test
individuel et statistique la parole est
donc à Monsieur Marc ferci rapporteur de
la commission des lois
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration général de la
République
merci
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et des citoyens de
1789 l'exprime en son article premer les
hommes naissent et demeurent libres et
égau en droit les distinctions sociales
ne peuvent être fondé que sur l'utilité
commune je n'ai pas l'habitude
d'utiliser des témoignages personnels
dans mon travail parlementaire mais je
vais faire aujourd'hui une exception
pour montrer que ce qu'exprime ici la
déclaration ne s'applique pas toujours
en France
je voudrais vous parler d'un proche
parent il s'appelle Jean Jean a obtenu
il y a des années de cela une thèse de
doctorat en physique option mécanique
des fluides il a par la suite publié de
nombreux articles dans des revues
scientifiques de niveau international il
intervient aujourd'hui comme exert pour
auditer l'efficacité des circuits de
refroidissement de nos centrales
nucléaires pour le dire simplement Jean
a très bien réussi sa vie
professionnelle le problème c'est que
Jean ne sait pas toujours appel je son
prénom de naissance est Saïd après
l'obtention de sa thèse Saïd a pendant
plusieurs années cherché un poste
d'ingénieur en lien avec ses compétences
pour pouvoir vivre il a été serveur à
travaillé sur des chantiers en désespoir
de cause Saï a décidé de demander à
modifié son état civil pour devenir gens
et il a au passage supprimé devant son
nom de famille le préfixe Ben qui
signifie fils de en arabe il a obtenu en
moins de 15 jours un entretien
d'embauche au auprès d'une entreprise
industrielle entretien qui a débouché
sur un recrutement ce n'est qu'après de
longues années de vie professionnelle
qu'il a repris son nom de
naissance le cas de Saïd n'est pas un
cas isolé nombreux sont nos concitoyens
qui à force de vous de se voir refuser
l'accès à un emploi à un logement décide
de changer de nom de mentir sur leur âge
ou sur leur adresse nombreux sont celles
et ceux qui sont contraints de se
dépouiller d'une partie de leur identité
pour pouvoir vivre dignement car ils
subissent des discriminations nombreux
aussi sont ceux qui se résignent et
poursuivent leur chemin sans que leur
soit apporté de réponse à la hauteur de
ce qu'ils
subissent cette violence symbolique que
vivent nombre de Françaises et de
français elle n'est pas acceptable en
République c'est l'objet de cette
proposition de loi discriminer c'est
traiter de manière différente de
personnes à la situation comparable qui
ne se distingue que par un critère
l'origine l'âge l'adresse par exemple
les discriminations remettent en
question le principe d'égalité qui est
au fondement de notre pacte républicain
elles sont source de ressentiment chez
les personnes qui les subissent et
favorisent le repli communautaire autant
que les tensions sociales les
discriminations sur le marché du travail
ont par ailleurs un coût économique
important comme le montre France
stratégie qui estimait dans un rapport
de 2016 que la suppression des
discriminations en matière d'emploi
augmenterait le PIB à long terme de 150
milliards d'euros selon l'INC la
proportion des personnes qui déclaré
avoir subi des discriminations est passé
de 14 à 18 % entre 2009 et 2020 par
ailleurs 42 % des personnes actives ont
déclaré avoir été témoins de
discrimination dans le cadre de leurs
activités professionnelles ces chiffres
montrre que les discriminations
ressenties restent intenses dans notre
pays les discriminations ressenties mais
aussi les discriminations objectives ce
que confirmait en 2020 le Conseil
d'analyse économique en synthétisant les
études réalisées depuis 20 ans ces
résultats peuvent surprendre car la
France dispose d'un arsenal juridique
très étoffé contre les discriminations
mais sa mise en œuvre est
particulièrement complexe pour les
victimes dans son rapport de 2020
consacré spécifiquement aux
discriminations lié aux origines le
Défenseur des droits notait ainsi que je
cite si le droit des discriminations
s'est considérablement développé le
recours contentieux est une démarche
lourde pour les victimes et son impact
reste limité comme outil de dissuasion
et de lutte contre les discriminations
de fait démontrer l'existence des
discriminations requier des actions
spécifiques l'enjeu est moins d'ajouter
aux 25 critères de discrimination que
mentionne le code pénal
que d'améliorer l'efficacité des outils
qui permettent de changer les pratiques
parmi ces outils figurent les tests de
discrimination qui ont fait l'objet
depuis plusieurs décennies de nombreux
travaux académiques et expériences de
terrain lesqueles ont validé leur
efficacité pour mettre en évidence les
discriminations deux types de test
méritent ici d'être distingué le test
statistique de discrimination tout
d'abord qui est généralement pratiqué
par des chercheurs indépendants il
consiste à adresser un nombre important
de candidatures similaires ne différant
que par un critère de discrimination
choisi ce afin d'observer d'éventuelles
différences de réponse de la part des
acteurs testés parce qu'il repose sur
des candidatures fictives ces test
statistique ne saurait être admis comme
preuve dans le cadre d'un recours
juridictionnel en revanche la publicité
des résultats aussi connu sous
langlicisme name and shame nommé et
faire honte peut conduire à changer les
comportements des acteurs mais ceci
suppose certaines conditions qui à l'UR
actuel ne sont pas réunis en France je
vais y revenir il est en particulier
nécessaire d'organiser un dialogue entre
les parties prenantes que sont les
représentants des entreprises et de
leurs salariés les associations qui
luttent contre les discriminations mais
aussi les chercheurs qui pratiquent les
tests ce afin de partager en amont la
méthode des tests et de définir les
conditions de publication de leurs
résultats il s'agit aussi d'accompagner
les organisations dans leur changement
de pratique ainsi dans les années
récentes des tests statistiques menés
par le gouvernement ont conduit à la
publication des nom d'entreprises
identifiées comme discriminantes mais ce
sans qu'une discussion et pu avoir lieu
en amont sur la méthodologie des tests
ceci a conduit ces entreprises à
contester les résultats et à envisager
des recours juridiques plutôt que de
modifier leur comportement pour remédier
à ce type de problème la présente
proposition met en place un cadre
permettant de discuter la robustesse des
tests statistiques avant de réaliser ces
derniers ce dans le but d' rendre les
résultats plus acceptables aux acteurs
les auditions menées durant la
préparation ont montré que les
partenaires sociaux souhaitent en
particulier être pleinement associés à
ce cadre un autre enjeu très actuel est
le développement de certains algorithmes
qui en exploitant l'intelligence
artificielle conduisent à discriminer
certains profils sans que ceci soit
nécessairement voulu ce type
d'algorithme se développe très
rapidement dans les services de
ressources humaines et les auditions de
chercheurs ou de DRH qui ont été mené
ont souligné l'intérêt des testings
statistiques pour repérer les biiss
qu'ils induisent à côté du test
statistique le test individuel à portée
judiciaire consiste quant à lui à mettre
en évidence une discrimination subie par
une personne réelle en adressant une
candidature similaire à la sienne mais
dépourvue du critère de discrimination
parce qu'il permet d'établir un
véritable préjudice ces testes sont
admis par le code pénal comme une preuve
de discrimination ouvrant droit à
réparation il faut ici signaler que les
tests de discrimination qu'il soit
statistique ou individuel se distingue
clairement de la démarche des
statistiques liées à l'origine ou
statistique d ethnique puisquil ne
repose nullement sur la collecte
systématique de données individuelles la
présente positionos de loi vise donc à
systématiser la pratique de ces deux
types de tests et ainsi à renforcer
l'arsenal de lutte contre les
discriminations dans notre pays elle
vise aussi à améliorer la connaissance
des phénomènes de
discrimination dans son article 1er elle
prévoit la création d'un service placé
sous l'autorité du Premier ministre et
ayant pour mission la lutte contre
toutes les formes de discrimination
notamment à travers la réalisation de
tests ce service cela a déjà été annoncé
à vocation à être la Délégation
interministérielle à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la haine
antillgbt la dilcra afin de garantir que
des moyens suffisants et nouveaux seront
dévolués à la dilcra pour assumer ses
nouvelles fonctions un amendement de 3
million d'euros au PLF 2024 a été déposé
par le groupe Renaissance et adopté en
première lecture l'article 2 prévoit que
soit créé au sein de ce service un
comité des parties prenantes celui-ci
serait chargé d'élaborer et de valider
la méthodologie des tests de proposer la
publication des résultats de ceci et de
formuler des recommandations à
destination des personnes morales
testées ceci doit permettre de diffuser
à l'ensemble des acteurs la culture des
tests et de consolider les connaissances
en matière de lutte contre les
discriminations afin de faire progresser
effectivement les pratiques l'article 3
de la proposition de loi donne par
ailleurs une base législative à la
diffusion des résultats des tests
statistiques et donc à la publication
des noms des organisations dont le
comportement discriminatoire a été
soulevé par les tests afin d'améliorer
les pratiques des acteurs cet article
prévoit que pour éviter la publication
des résultats les personnes morales
concernées qui pourront qui pourront
être des entreprises mais aussi des
administrations puissent définir par le
dialogue social un plan de lutte contre
les discriminations sous peine de
sanction
pécuniaère durant nos débats en
commission le texte a connu un certain
nombre d'améliorations que je veux ici
saluer les amendements de différents
groupes ont notamment été adoptés pour
inclure les partenaires sociaux
interprofessionnel dans le comité des
parties prenantes ou encore pour imposer
la consultation du Défenseur des droits
sur le programme de t statistique défin
par le gouvernement un amendement a
également été adopté pour réhausser à 1
% de la masse salariale le niveau de
l'amende administratif d en cas
d'inaction suite à un test
positif pour conclure je veux dire ici
clairement que les tests ne sont pas une
réponse miracle au problème de
discrimination tout d'abord parce qu'il
repose sur le principe de candidature et
ne serait par exemple identifier des
discriminations qui en cours dans le
déroulement de la carrière
professionnelle ensuite et surtout les
tests doivent s'insérer dans une
stratégie globale qui inclut notamment
des actions de sensibilisation de
formation mais aussi des sanctions c'est
le sens de cette proposition de loi que
de contribuer à la mise en œuvre de
cette stratégie
globale chers collègues je suis
convaincu que tout n'a pas été tenté
pour faire reculer les discriminations
dans notre pays systématiser la pratique
des test est une voix prometteuse je
vous propose de l'emprunter pour donner
plus de consistance à la promesse
d'égalité ain je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame berérangerre
Couillard ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et la lutte contre les
[Applaudissements]
discriminations merci Madame madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
lutter contre toutes les formes de
discrimination qui est au cœur de ma
mission c'est avant tout agir en faveur
de l'égalité bien que l'égalité soit
inscrite dans la loi de notre pays elle
est encore loin d'être une réalité pour
tous il s'agit à présent de donner à
chacun la possibilité d'accéder à
l'emploi ou au logement qu'il mérite et
au prêt bancaire pour financer ses
projets selon les données de C près d'un
Français sur C déclare avoir été victime
de discrimination au cours des 5
dernières années parmi les personnes
immigrés et leurs descendants 82 %
déclarent ressentir des discriminations
liées principalement à leur origine ou à
leur couleur de peau l'accès à l'emploi
et au logement sont particulièrement
concernés l'être humain ne manque jamais
d'imagination quand il s'agit d'écartés
sont semblables pour ces différences
ainsi cette discrimination frappent
aussi les femmes tout au long de leur
vie qu'ell soit proche de connaître la
maternité ou qu'ell soit considéré par
certains comme trop âgé pour exercer
leur métier cette discrimination
n'éparne pas non plus les personnes en
situation de handicap les personnes LGBT
plus ou encore les seniors plus
largement il est donc grand temps d'agir
cette proposition de loi elle concrétise
la promesse faite par le Président de la
République de lutter plus efficacement
contre les discriminations dans notre
pays elle est en parfaite adéquation
avec la volonté du gouvernement et
s'inscrit dans le plan national de lutte
contre le racisme l'antisémitisme et les
discriminations liées à l'origine
2023-2026 annoncé en janvier 2023 par la
première ministre ce plan et cette
politique publique je suis chargé de les
porter avec détermination pour que nous
ayons enfin des résultats concrets je me
réjouis que la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale est adopté cette
proposition de loi portée par le député
Marc Feracci dont je tiens ici à saluer
l'engagement pour ces sujets qui sont
essentiels cette proposition de loi
porte des mesures cruciales pour lutter
contre des discriminations qui vont à
l'encontre de nos valeurs républicaines
et de l'idéal de méritocratie ce texte
il soulligne l'ambition de lutter contre
les pratiques discriminatoir en
utilisant des tests statistiques et
individuels il contribue à la justice
sociale et à la cohésion de notre pays
en montrant à chaque citoyen que ses
origines sa couleur de peau sa supposé
son âge ou encore son orientation
sexuelle ne devrait jamais entraver ses
chances d'emploi limiter son accès au
logement ou au crédit bancaire certaines
personnes sont contraintes de changer de
nom de mentir sur leur âge leur adresse
pour échapper à ces discriminations
souvent la résignation les gagne cette
proposition de loi vise précisément à
leur redonner espoir et à leur permett
d'obtenir
réparation pour changer les choses en
profondeur il n faut d'abord changer les
comportements des entreprises et des
administrations pour atteindre cet
objectif ce texte renforce l'arsenal de
lutte contre les discriminations en
généralisant le texting statistique le
testing statistique consiste à envoyer
des candidatures fictives à des
employeurs qui vont différencier par des
critères de discrimination cela
permettra de collecter des données à
grande échelle pour analyser des
situations rencontrées par nos
concitoyens et aussi détecter les
entreprises et les administration qui
sont discriminantes l'objectif est de
permettre le test de 500 entreprises en
2024 celles qui seront identifiées comme
défaillantes et qui n'engagent pas les
actions correctrices nécessaires pour
limiter les discriminations se verront
signalé par la publication des résultats
des tests ainsi ce texte prévoit
d'encadrer juridiquement le name and
shame pour sécuriser la publication de
ces
résultats certains nous signaleront lors
de ce débat que l'arsenal juridique
existe déjà vous avez raison le principe
des tests apparaît comme un outil de
preuve dans le cadre d'une action en
justice depuis le début des années 2000
mais cela ne fonctionne pas le droit à
la réparation est inopérant en 2020 il
n'y a eu aucune condamnation pénale en
matière de discrimination en France
aucune nous devons donc rendre le droit
à la réparation plus effectif cette
proposition de loi va permettre de
recréer un parcours de justice pour les
personnes qui se sentiront discr iné le
test individuel va se concentrer
justement sur ces situations de
discrimination vécu par des personnes
réelles au lieu de collecter des données
à grande échelle cette approche se base
sur les signalements de discrimination
fait par les victimes elles-mêmes les
signalements sont examinés afin de
déterminer si une discrimination a
effectivement eu lieu et d'apporter un
soutien dans sa démarche juridique le
testing statistique et le testing
individuel sont complémentaires dans
notre lutte contre les discriminations
je les soutiens car j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir quant aux résultats qu'ils
obtiendront ce dispositif global
s'appuiera sur la Délégation
interministérielle à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la haine
antil-lgbt et aura pour mission
d'organiser les tests statistiques à
grande échelle il ne vise pas à
concurrencer le Défenseur des droits qui
fait un travail reconnu pour identifier
et combattre les inégalités de notre
société mais plutôt à consolider une
approche
complémentaire dans ce cadre la
proposition de loi prévoit la création
d'un comité des parties prenantes qui
sera constitué de plusieurs
représentants ce comité inclura des
parlementaires des experts sur les
sujets économiques juridiques ou encore
sociaux ou encore aussi un représentant
du Défenseur des droits je sais que sa
composition va occuper une partie de nos
débats le comité des partis des parties
prenantes son rôle sera principalement
de décider la méthodologie des test
et de déterminer les actions
correctrices que les entreprises et les
administrations discriminantes pourront
mettre en place mesdames et messieurs
les députés cette proposition de loi
représente une étape cruciale dans notre
lutte contre les
discriminations ce combat ne devrait pas
être une question de couleur politique
lutter contre les discriminations
transcende lesclivage politique et met
en évidence notre obligation d'agir je
suis convaincu qu'une majorité peut être
trouvée sur ce texte N citoyens
attendent de nous que nous soyons à la
hauteur c'est ainsi que nous ferons
vivre la promesse républicaine d'égalité
je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur jean-phélix
Aquaviva madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues aujourd'hui je veux m'adresser
à toutes les victimes de discrimination
cette proposition de loi leur est bien
évidemment dédiée parce que la haine de
l'autre n'a pas sa place dans notre
société parce que les discrimination
porte atteinte à notre principe de
fraternité et enfin parce que les
pratiques discriminatoires perpétuent
les inégalités conduisent à des
injustices le constat nous le
connaissons tous les fractures qui
traversent notre société contribuent à
un accroissement des discriminations
sous toutes leurs formes je salue donc
le travail engagé de notre rapporteur
cette proposition de loi nous permet de
débattre du testing des faç d'améliorer
la lutte contre les discrimination en
particulier au travail mais surtout elle
doit nous permettre d'avancer pour
changer le quotidien de nos
concitoyens je sais que beaucoup de
chiffres ont déjà été versés au débat
mais notre groupeot souhaite alerter sur
deux progressions inquiétantes d'une
part la discrimination contre les femmes
le motif sexiste est devenu la
principale source de discrimination pour
elle même devant les origines 47 %
d'entre elles indiqueent d'avoir été
discriminé en raison de leur sexe 47 %
c'est quasiment une femme sur de
d'autres autre part un point sur lequel
plusieurs de mes collègues ultramarins
souhaitent insister les traitements
inégalitaires qui touchent durement les
citoyens d'outr mère cet aspect est trop
souvent négligé mais ce sont 32 % des
natifs d'outr mè qui sont victimes de
discrimination au-delà des propos ces
discrimination ont aussi un impact sur
la vie quotidienne elles sont des
obstacles au logement à l'emploi aux
études aux
opportunités notre groupe accueille
favorablement ces mesures qui visent à
accroître le recours au test de
discrimination et au NCH
les peines prévues dans notre code pénal
ne suffisent plus pour lutter contre les
discriminations l'État doit également
recueillir des données diffuser des
bonnes pratiques et accompagner les
victimes actuellement le recours au test
de discrimination souffre d'un cadre
législatif limité qui n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux notre groupe juge ces
test individuels statistiques essentiels
ils permettent de cibler les entreprises
qui discriminent je rappelle qu'il
faudra des moyens si nous voulons
permettre au service de l'État de
déployer de manière efficace ces tests
là où nous avons petite inquiétude c'est
sur la capacité de l'État accompagner
les victimes dans les tests individuels
ces tests ont une importance
particulière déjà parce qu'il concerne
une victime bien réelle mais surtout
quand notre code pénal les reconnaît
comme preuves admises lors d'un procès
contre l'employeur
discriminant ce texte repose sur un
service centralisé sans doute laadilcra
mais comment accompagner les victimes
sur le terrain dans les territoire c'est
n'y on pas un accès direct selon nous
l'accompagnement pourrait se faire au
niveau local et il n'est pas possible de
le laisser à la charge des seules
associations sur le name on chame
lorsqu'une entreprise discrimine au
citoyens se refuse à prendre des mesures
correctrices publier son nom et mettre à
la vue de tous ces pratiques est une
nécessité s'attaquer à l'image de marque
est le meilleur moyen de faire réagir
une entreprise il ne s'agit pas
seulement de la pointere du doigt cette
sanction doit aussi la pousser à prendre
sans délai des mesures pour rectifier le
tir en la matière la règle doit être la
tolérance zéro notre groupe soutient le
choix d'une amende administrative et
porte un amendement pour accroîre son
montant en cas de récidive cette fermeté
est nécessaire les pratique
discriminante violent le pacte
républicain crée des fractures entre les
citoyens et on en plus un impact néfaste
sur l'économie dans l'attente de ce
renforcement du volet répression notre
groupe votera bien évidemment pour cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est maintenant à
Madame Clara Chassignol chassagnol
excusez-moi
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues une enquête de l'INC publiée
en juillet 2022 révèle qu'en 10 ans de
2009 à 2019 les personnes qui déclarent
avoir subi des discriminations sont
passées de 14 % à 18 %. le rapport 2020
de la Défenseur des droits indique que
l'origine réel ou supposé constitue le
deuxème critère de discrimination après
le genre et concerne 11 % de la
population aussi lorsque Yassine Aminata
ou Radija candidate pour louer un
logement privé ils ont un tiers de
chance en moins d'obtenir un premier
rendez-vous avec le propriétaire ces
discriminations sont des barrières
invisibles elles empêchent certains de
nos concitoyens de jouir pleinement de
leur droit et des opportunités qu'il
rencontrent même lorsque l'on ne veut
pas les voir elles existent et les
exemples qui nous les rappellent par des
témoignages des plaintes des recherches
nous procurent le sentiment douloureux
d'une conscience asserrée des inégalités
qui repose sur l'essentialisation des
individus dès lors qu'ils sont assignés
par un employeur un bailleur ou toute
autre personne leur refusant l'accès à
un service pour ce qu'ils sont le
sentiment d'injustice qui en résulte
engendre des blessures de la résignation
une perte de confiance c'est une
violence sourde qui s'impose elle met en
cause l'égalité républicaine et
l'article 1er de la Déclaration des
Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen les
hommes naissent et demeurent libres et
égau en droit les distinctions social ne
peuvent être fondés que sur l'utilité
commune les discriminations sont non
seulement un fléo pour celles et ceux
qui en sont victimes mais aussi pour la
nation elles sont contraires à l'utilité
commune leur suppression dans l'accès à
l'emploi pourrait d'ailleurs augmenter
le PIB jusqu'à 14 % selon un rapport de
France stratégie en
2016 ces discriminations peuvent toucher
chacun d'entre nous à un moment de nos
vies heureusement la loi les condamne
malgré cela nous savons que le non
recours au droit à déposé plainte est
massif si bien que nous sommes
incapables de les identifier avec
précision de les mesurer réellement et
surtout de faire que la société apporte
aux victimes une réparation or pour
réparer il faut prouver la la
discrimination qui ne s'affiche jamais
comme telle c'est la raison pour
laquelle les tests dit individuels
permettent d'apporter la preuve d'une
discrimination grâce à une candidature
fictive similaire actuellement la
pratique de ces tests est très limitée
bien que des associations des avocats
des individus ou même la Défenseur des
droits puisse en réaliser nous soutenons
donc l'objectif d'un service public pour
les intensifier et apporter aux victimes
un soutien matériel rapide et effectif à
cet objectif déjà ambitieux cette
proposition de loi ajoute un cadre au
test 10 statistique qui repose sur
l'envoi de candidature fictive au moyen
d'une méthodologie qui est adapté par
des chercheurs lors d'une précédente
campagne de testing massive sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République il avait été révélé que
plusieurs entreprises avaient des
pratiques discriminatoires allant
jusqu'à 20 à 30 % de chance en moins
d'être contacté après une candidate
spontanée avec un nom de famille
maghrébin toutefois affirm ce constat
n'apportait pas de sanction ni de réelle
transformation la légitimité d'une telle
publication des résultats avait alors
été questionné au regard d'une méthode
qui était controversée grâce au travail
du rapporteur qui a eu l'occasion de
suivre de près les étapes de ces
expérimentations cette proposition de
loi permettra de réaliser des tests
statistiques selon une méthode validée
par un comité des parties prenantes les
résultats des tests positifs aux
discrimination pourront désormais faire
l'objet d'une amende administrative
ainsi que d'une publication en
commission nous avons d'ailleurs doublé
cette amende de 0,5 à 1 % de la masse
salariale de l'entreprise concernée et
nous souhaitons qu'elle puisse être
renforcé en cas de réitération cet
encadrement permet de sécuriser
juridiquement le name and chame bien
qu'ici l'objectif ne soit pas de jeter
l'eau probre mais bien d'engager un
dialogue sur la base de recommandations
à travers ce texte c'est une pression
qui sera mise à l'encontre de ceux qui
discriminent souvent gouverné par des
stéréotypes qui ne sont pas
conscientisés elle contraindra les
employeurs à repenser leur processus de
recrutement
en conséquence la société sera mieux
préparée à lutter contre les
discriminations sachant qu'elles ne
seront pas tolérées et qu'il y aura la
possibilité de les démontrer les
pratiques devront évoluer et avec elles
les mentalités dont les changements sont
souvent lents et incrémentaux lors de la
loi sur l'égalité réelle imposant aux
entreprises de respecter l'égalité de
traitement entre les femmes et les
hommes la pression de la loi a contraint
une ingénierie collective pour trouver
des solutions le travail mené en
commission a permis d'ajouter de manière
transpartisane la représentation des
partenaires sociaux dans le comité des
partis prenante et j'espère que la même
coopération présidera pour renforcer le
rôle des associations afin de relayer
les problématiques qu'elle rencontent
sur le
terrain en commission aussi tandis que
le rassemblement national n'a cessé de
minimiser les discriminations j'espère
que les ban de cet hémicycle qui sont
attachés à la justice sociale refusant
d'ignorer ces discriminations et
l'ampleur de la tâche pour les résoudre
seront au côté du groupe renaissance
pour voter ces solutions concrètes
encadré et concerté pour que l'État soit
un acteur volontariste de l'aide aux
victimes et de l'accompagne des
recruteurs afin de contribuer à
instaurer une véritable égalité des
chances je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Emmanuel
[Applaudissements]
bler
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
chers collègues luté contre les
discriminations est un combat porté
effectivement par l'ensemble des groupes
politiques au sein de notre de notre
assemblée selon le rapport de
l'Observatoire des inégalités selon les
données de Linc près d'un Français sur 5
déclare avoir été victime d'une pratique
discriminatoire dans les 5 dernières
années notamment fondées sur des
considérations
sexistes même si les auteurs de ce
rapport reconnaissent je cite une
société plus ouverte et tolérante qu'il
y a 20 ans il nous faut continuer à
lutter sans relâche contre les
discriminations quell qu'elles soi qu'il
me soit permis dans cette hémicycle
d'avoir une pensée particulière pour nos
concitoyens ultramarins dont un sur TR
déclare avoir été victime de
discrimination sur le territoire
hexagonal et ce dans une relative
indifférence il faut le dire des
gouvernements successifs peu importe son
sexe son origine son handicap son
engagement politique sa couleur de peau
son lieu de domicile sa son orientation
sexuelle sa religion ou encore son âge
on ne distingue pas parmi les Français
le combat qui est la lutte contre les
discrimination est aujourd'hui dévoyée
par la majorité qui veut faire un coup
de comme en ajoutant une nouvelle charge
à nos entreprises sans véritablement
régler le problème de fond du reste et
c'est très récent dans un article publié
dans Capital le 22 novembre dernier
monsieur le rapporteur vous indiquz que
ce texte ne n'est pas la réponse miracle
oui parce que quel est le fond du du
problème ceux qui nous présentent ce
texte aujourd'hui n'ont pas la volonté
de combattre fermement par la voix
judiciaire les discriminations nous
avons proposé à plusieurs reprises en
commission et en matière de
discrimination comme pour l'ensemble des
crimes et délits la dissuasion repose
sur la certitude de la peine or avec
vous la seule certitude que l'on est en
tout cas que les Français puissent avoir
ce sont des peines non exécutées il
suffit d'ailleurs d'aller voir les
chiffres du ministère de de la justice
qui explique que 41 % des délinquants
condamnés à de prison ferme ne passent
pas une seule nuit en prison comment
voulez-vous combattre les discrimination
sans punir les auteurs en fonction de la
gravité de leurs actes plutôt que
d'élaborer une politique pénale globale
et efficace vous préférez nous présenter
une nouvelle lubie bureaucratique avec
cette proposition de loi vous donnez
donc de nouvelles à la dilcra mission
qui se recoupe par ailleurs avec celle
du Défenseur des droits et vous créer
une procédure de type et j'insiste
inquisitoriale contre nos entreprises et
nos administrations la première version
présentée par le rapport soulevit bien
des questionnements notamment vis-à-vis
du respect des principes essentiels de
l'État de droit et de notre démocratie
cette version ne prévoyait aucun
contradictoire ni aucune marge
d'appréciation notre groupe a donc
déposé des amendements venant rappeler à
la majorité présidentielle
que les entreprises ont le droit de se
défendre le rapporteur a corrigé sa
copie en reprenant à son compte nos
amendements c'est heureux monsieur le
rapporteur c'est heureux mais soyons
clair en l'état votre texte n'offre
aucune solution satisfaisante pour
lutter contre les discriminations
monsieur le rapporteur plutôt que
d'appliquer sérieusement le droit
existant à la matière vous choisissez la
voie du la voix du droit comportemental
avec le name and shame en français
puisque nous sommes au Parlement en
français euh le nommer et faire honte
nommer et faire honte une pratique
anglo-saxonne en fait vous proposez au
français une société de contrat cette
pratique vient clouer au piloris des
entreprises parfois sur la base de
simple suspicion de discrimination le
concept de nommer et faire honte
viendrait mettre un écran de fumée
devant notre code de procédure pénale
par exemple outil qui vise pourtant à
protéger les libertés individuelles dans
la sincérité des preuves je sais que
certains ont déposé des amendements en
ce sens et nous les soutiendrons en fait
vous menacez les entreprises à défaut de
les associer à ce combat qui est la
lutte contre les discriminations ou de
les condamner pénalement effectivement
lorsqu'elles en commettent c'est pour
cette raison que notre groupe
sollicitera évidemment la suppression
des articles de ce texte qui n'apporte
aucune réponse concrète à nos
concitoyens victimes de discrimination
je vous le redis ou je le dis
l'inscription de ce texte à l'ordre du
jour des travaux dans notre assemblée me
paraît extrêmement éloigné de ce
qu'attendent les Français chers
collègues les Françis peuvent compter
sur le groupe rassemblement national
pour descendre défendre pardon
véritablement face à toutes les
discriminations en assurant le respect
de notre Constitution avec la volonté
politique de mettre fin au laxisme en la
matière comme dans tous les domaines je
vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant monsieur Carlos Martin
[Applaudissements]
bilongo de discrimination avec le
rassemblement national vas-y
car madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur rapporteur chers
collègu la méritocratie don parle le
temps nous conduit aujourd'hui à
débattre de ce projet de loi visant à
contre la discrimination par la pratique
de test individuel et de statistique
mais comment sommes-nous arrivés là
cette proposition de loi n'estelle pas
elle-même la preuve que discrimination
du fait d'un genre d'une origine d'une
religion sont encore trop nombreuses en
France il s'appelle zonzamizou zainb
Jabali Mamadou Kamara albertevki vafiila
Marwan zugag Mohamed almukadem Luuk
bajipsi adamoumar bint aen Nea tous et
tout discriminés après avoir postulé
après avoir obten B + 5 mais qu'est-ce
qui n'a pas marché dans notre pays pour
que ces enfants qui sont allés à l'école
de la République soit obligés de devoir
déménager quitter la France pour obtenir
un poste à hauteur de leur diplôme et
pourtant ces enfants ont été à l'école
publi avec un fronton liberté égalité
fraternité il n'y a pas plus difficile
que de sorter la discrimination en
l'embauche la France n'a jamais cherché
à être les origines ou la religion des
soldats pendant la première ou la
seconde guerre mondiale pendant les tres
glorieuses la France est construite avec
des travailleurs immigrés ou expatriés
selon la façon dont regarde le monde les
enfants de ces travailleurs ont fait des
enfants et les voilà aujourd'hui
discriminal l'embauche quelle honte RAR
sont les discriminations pour les postes
de premier de corvé femmes de ménage
éboueurs maçon chauffeur de bus agent de
sécurité travailleus et travailleurs qui
sont autour de cette éissie qui nous
font honneur par leur bravour il n'y a
pas de discrimination pour eux monsieur
le
rapporteur personnellement je n'ai pas
eu PPL de 2008 à 2013 lorsque je
cherchais un poste en tant courrier
après mon BP mécanique et mon bac pro
techn à d'usinage aucun problème pour
trouver un poste dès l'heure où j'ai
postulé pour trouver une entreprise en
BTS en alternance les premiers qui sont
arrivés je vous raconte tout j'ai 18 ans
et c'est une violence inuie de subir la
discrimination en
nous sommes C en sal d'attente nous
attendons entretien un par un je suis
impatient d'attendre mon tour voilà
Carlos Martin bilongo C'est à vous je me
lève mais le recuteur ne pose pas le
regard sur moi coïncidence je ne sais
pas première phrase d'entretien sera je
ne vous voyais pas comme ça monsieur
bilongo coïncidence cet entretien va se
solder par un échec coïncidence cela se
répétera à C reprises pour C entretiens
différents
peut-être une coïncidence peut-être que
je suis mauvais en tout cas je suis ici
à l'Assemblée nationale alors très vite
j'ai commencé à mettre ma photo sur mon
CV au moins comme ça il y a pas de
secret sans évoquer avec vous la
discrimination à l'adresse à l'âge ou
sinon à la validité parce que si vous
vous appelez Juliette Dupont vous êtes
discriminé si vous habitez viel belle
garge ou sarcelle alors si votre prénom
est myiam votre nom est makunza et vous
habitez sttin c'est un triptique alors
certes chaque avancée pour mettre fin à
C discrimination distinguer je reconnais
monsieur le rapporteur mais je c que ce
projet de loi ne mesure pas l'empleur du
défi auquel nous sommes confrontés et
d'ailleurs les B son vid parceon mesure
parlementaire tout ce qui nous reste à
faire en 2023 ce n'est pas normal d'êre
iciation vous l'z dit par rapport au PIB
et même économiement parlant ce n'est
pas normal
aujourd'hui mais je c encore une fois
cette réforme est trop timide floue et
manque d'ambition car les discrimination
aujourd'hui ne s'aditiononne plus elle
se multiplie en 20 ans on assiste à un
doublement des discriminations per
embauche en vertu de l'origine de la
race ou de l'ethnie qu'importe les
études menées les nombre les nombreuses
compétences émunérées çapp les Karim en
France c'est avoir 32 % de chance en
moins d'être contacté pour un entretien
d'embauche porter le nom de Mia c'est
envoyé 24 CV comm France on verra 5 cv
pour être rappelé alors certes le
testing l'éargissement des moyens de
preuve sont des moyens de lutte contre
la discrimination mais je crains que
cellà ne soit pas soit insuffisant je
regrette le manque d'effet disoisif
ainsi que le manque de Clairé de cette
loi mais quen est-il de la personne
discriminée monsieur le rapporteur qu'en
est-il de ces projets de vie aura-t-elle
un poste à hauteur de ses diplômes
aura-t-elle un logement je ne pense pas
vous proposez la création d'un service
mis sur la tut du Premier ministre sans
mesurer les risques de conflit d'intérêt
qui s'y attachent comment garantir la
bonne foi d'un organisme visé lorsqu'il
existe un lienchique contre la première
ministre et son administration comment
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas de fuite ni
d'arbitrage alors que l'adistration en
est la cible ceci çapparentera un igpn
bis entre-temps pour la personne visée
la discrimination la personne visée par
discrimination le train pourrait les
passer et c'est ça le sujet
aujourd'hui vous mettez en place un
outil de mesure qui ne pourra pas
devenir aujourd'hui une politique
publique qui est nécessaire je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Raphaël
[Applaudissements]
chéenberger madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous sommes le 6
décembre tant qu'alsacien c'est la
Saint-Nicolas et je le dis pour
commencer avec une petite citation qu'on
aurait pu attribuer
à cette idée à cette proposition de loi
en
Alsace moi j'aurais pu qualifier ça de
schnops idée
idée sarenu non pas qu'elle soit
mauvaise non pas que l'objet à laquelle
cette idée tend à s'intéresser à
s'attaquer ou que le problème que cette
proposition cherche à solutionner ne
soit pas réel bien au contraire mais
l'idée en tant que telle est d'une
complexité sans nom et me semble
particulièrement
inopérante nous allons donc envoyer des
milliers de CV de faux CV aux
entreprises pour tester si il y a des
problèmes de discrimination
systémique voilà
le l'action que va faire l'état ce que
va financer l'argent du contribuable
voilà une idée particulièrement complexe
d'abord dans la définition des
discriminations aujourd'hui notre droit
reconnaît 24 discriminations
différentes dois-je rappeler le débat
sur la glotophobie que nous avons eu à
l'occasion de la législature précédente
grand moment de la vie
parlementaire et vous imaginez bien que
c'est cette liste de discrimination ne
cessera comme tout dans le débat public
de se spécialiser de se
détailler combien de discrimination
devrons-nous tester dans quelques
années l'augmentation de toutes ces
discriminations que nous testons ne
a-t-elle pas en tant que tel le problème
de fond d'un certain nombre de
discrimination moi c'est une question
que que je me pose autre problème on
voit bien là une forme de renversement
de la situation on va poser une
présomption de culpabilité quasi
systématique sur les entreprises voilà
là encore une action assez
antiéconomique et qui vise à considérer
tout le monde comme coupable avant même
d'avoir identifié s'il y avait à cet
endroit un problème enfin les visées
contentieuses qui sont porté par ce
texte me semblent complexe d'ailleurs
même la défenseuse des droits clair et
donc dans son avis du mois de novembre
se montre opposé au test individuels à
Visé contentieuse mais au-delà de la
complexité de cette idée voilà qu'un
autre problème apparaît monsieur le
rapporteur puisque il faut s'intéresser
aux conséquences de la mise en place de
ce système sur les entreprises
la complexité le risque lié à la
judiciarisation du processus d'embauche
va nécessairement conduire à des
réactions des entreprises alors on peut
espérer naïvement que la réaction c'est
qu'il n'y aura plus de
discrimination j'imagine que la première
réaction des entreprises sera d'abord de
se protéger juridiquement et pour cela
d'externaliser les fonctions de
recrutement alors pour C certaines
entreprises pas de souci pour les plus
petites ce sera peut-être plus compliqué
quen sera-t-il
monsieur le rapporteur les prestataires
de l'externalisation de ce recrutement
faut-il s'interroger ici dans cet
hémicycle sur les risques de conflit
d'intérêts qui ont déjà été soulignés
concernant un précédent texte celui sur
le plein emploi pour lequel sur la
modification de Pôle Emploi pour lequel
le rapporteur qui avait été désigné par
la commission des affaires sociales a dû
se retirer monsieur le rapporteur faute
faute de conflit d'intérêt compte tenu
des marchés publics liant l'entreprise
dans laquelle il est actionnaire
à à au prestataires de de l'État et au
conflit d'intérêts mis en évidence enfin
dernier élément je veux dénoncer et de
façon très forte la logique de name and
shame cette logique qui tend à se
substituer à la justice à transformer
les administrations en juge sans passer
sans passer par le principe de
séparation des pouvoirs qui est pourtant
consubstantiel à notre démocratie et à
notre République qui est
consubstantielle au droits continental
pour migrer progressivement vers une
logique où chacun peut accuser dans
l'espace public même les administrations
sans nécessairement qu'il y ait eu de
décision de justice la République ce
n'est pas ça la République ce n'est pas
humilié la République c'est'est
identifiée c'est jugé c'est punir et sa
permettre à chacun de se réparer sans
avoir été humilié fusent des entreprises
fusent des personnes moral voilà les
raisons pour lesquelles le groupe les
républicains s'opposera à l'adoption de
ce
texte je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Philippe
latombe madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues è au nom du groupe
démocrate je salue la création de ce
service chargé de la lutte contre les
discriminations même si nous disposons
d'un arsenal législatif et réglementaire
solide pour lutter contre les
discriminations nous savons qu'elle
persiste les victimes renoncent trop
souvent à engager une procédure
judiciaire car il est difficile de
prouver qu'elles subissent des
discriminations il faut alors réfléchir
à la mise en place d'outils qui peuvent
accompagner le droit pour mieux lutter
contre les discriminations et dissuader
les auteurs la création de ce service
placé sous le contrôle de la première
ministre et donc la bienvenue alors que
les tests de discrimination sont
utilisés depuis longtemps dans d'autres
pays et que leur efficacité était
largement prouvée ce service est un
nouvel outil intéressant pour lutter
contre les discriminations en intégrant
des personnes qualifiées des
représentants des entreprises et des
administrations susceptibles d'être
testé des parlementaires mais également
des représentants syndicaux comme nous
l'avons proposé nous avons proposé de le
faire en commission ce service ne vise
pas seulement à réprimer les
discriminations il a vocation à
accompagner à la fois les victimes dans
la défense de leurs droits et les
entreprises et les administrations dans
la négociation et la correction de ces
discriminations c'est notamment la
possibilité de publication de ces tests
révélant en public la pratique de
discrimination par une personne morale
ou privée qui doit permettre de prévenir
et d'encourager à la correction de ces
situations de
discrimination notre groupe a souhaité
toutefois que ce texte que ce texte
puisse intégrer des apports afin de
l'adapter au développement de
l'intelligence artificielle et cela en
commission nous avons ont été déclaré
irreceva au titre de l'article 40 dont
acte nous ne les avons pas redéposé en
vue de cette séance néanmoins nous ne
pouvons pas nous priver des capacités de
l'intelligence artificielle pour nous
aider à la réalisation de ces tests l'IA
est un outil qui nous permettra de
décupler nos délais de traitement mais
nous devons être également vigilant
quand au biais de ces algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle que ce soit
en apprentissage initial le modèle dit
fondation ou en spécialisation le fine
tuning et demain en
auto-apprentissage ces amendements
avaient pour objet d'ouvrir le débat
j'espère monsieur le rapporteur madame
la ministre que nous pourrons faire
évoluer ce texte dans un second temps en
tous les cas le groupe démocrate votera
ce texte évidemment je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Marietta
caramoli merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers
collègues la proposition de de loi dont
nous discutons ce jour est doublement
intéressante d'une part par son objet et
d'autre part par son objectif les
orateurs précédents l'ont déjà bien
rappelé son objet est la mise en place
d'un dispositif via un service d'état et
l'utilisation de moyens spécifiques en
vue de dépister si vous me permettez et
d'objectiver l'existence de
discrimination et d'y mettre fin autant
que possible dans le domaine de l'emploi
et de l' au travail chacune et chacun de
nos concitoyens peut être victime
aujourd'hui d'une discrimination pour
des motifs variés fondés souvent sur des
présjugés il est donc important de
pouvoir identifier les situations et de
les rapporter notamment par des tests
individuels et des statistiques la
méthode donc reconnue de
testing ou de la réalisation de tests
comme on appelle de la discrimination ou
de la non discrimination selon un
critère donné la proposition fonde donc
en mati de lutte contre les inégalités
dans l'accès au travail un dispositif
nouveau a priori méritant l'intérêt et
le soutien d'une large majorité de
députés mais là comme ailleurs le
trouble vient non de la finalité
poursuivi monsieur le rapporteur mais
des moyens et des modalités surtout
choisies la première observation est que
le champ des discriminations retenu est
étroit on peut ici regretter que la
discrimination dans les domaines du
logement ou de la santé ne figureent pas
dans dans l'escarcelle du futur service
de l'État que souhaite créer le texte la
deuxième est que la modalité choisit les
tests soit une voie alors qu'il en
existe d'autres pour permettre pour
mettre en évidence les dites
discrimination on pense par exemple aux
audit le projet recelle d'autres
imprécisions ainsi la proposition
prévoit un comité des parties prenantes
mais reste assez général sur la
composition et sa finalité vous les avez
parlé tout à l'heure madame la ministre
et nous attendons des précisions
celui-ci donc est notamment chargé
d'élaborer la méthodologie des tests et
des mettes des avis parilleur par
ailleurs la proposition désigne des
catégories de participants à ce comité
de façon générale sans précision des des
équilibres la procédure donc qui suivent
que suivent les avis fournis elle est
précisée lors de l'examen en commission
le statut donc de la vie donnée sur la
base des tests n'est pas clairement
établi est-ce c'est un constat est-ce
que c'est une recommandation pouvant
être contestée j'en viens à ce qui pose
vraiment un problème de fond sur lequel
vraiment nous souhaitons qu'on puisse
faire évoluer les débats aujourd'hui
dans cet hémicycle dans l'avis qu'elle a
émis sur ce projet de loi la défenseur
de droits si elle se félicite du sens de
la proposition énonce clairement qu'elle
est défavorable au fait de donner à un
service de l'état des compétences défin
au motif que ce service ne présente
aucune garantie d'indépendance depuis
une cinquantaine d'autorités
administratives indépendant
ont été créé avec une double
préoccupation d'une part assurer la
protection des libertés des citoyens à
la sousant plus possible au contrôle
ministériel et d'autre part développer
la réglementation et la surveillance des
activités dans des secteurs nouveaux ou
sensibl en les confiant des autorités
techniques facilement identifiables et
éloigné du pouvoir d'État
jugé
interventionniste ces autorités donc ont
un statut qui garantit leur indépendance
c'est important et cette question est
centrale dans la création de la nouvelle
entité proposée pourquoi vouloir créer
une instance avec des compétences que
pourrait exercer deur et déjà une
autorité administrative indépendante
existante et en lui accordant les
ressources
nécessaires la simplicité les citoyens
ne l'auront pas automatiquement puisque
certes ils auront le choix entre deux
instances mais selon deux voies
possibles et des résultats différents
là réside le mystère de cette
proposition de loi certes intéressante
mais sans les garanties répondant à
toutes les questions qu'elle pose
deorest et déjà le groupe socialiste et
apparenté a déposé plusieurs amendements
visant à la fois ou de manière
alternative à donné la nouvelle
compétence à la défenseur de droit en
cas de non transfert à celle-ci à la
consulter avant d'établir des programmes
de test statistiques et d'évaluation et
de discrimination à prévoir la
transmission à la justice des cas
constituant des infractions avérées a
institué un plancher aux amend
d'administrative et non un plafond tous
ces amendements étaient refusés monsieur
le rapporteur et madame la ministre lors
de leur discussion en commission des
lois aujourd'hui nous allons nous avons
déposé un certain nombre d'amendements
nous sommes dans l'attente de cette
discussion visant améliorer le texte et
nous serons constructifs et exigeants en
même temps nous attendons donc ce débat
pour pouvoir se positionner
définitivement mais à l'état actuel nous
pourrons pas soutenir ce
texte je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Jean-Charles
Larsonneur il a pas
étéutilisé madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
le sujet qui nous réunit aujourd qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui pardon est
éminemment important éminemment
important car il touche à notre cohésion
nationale et à notre pacte républicain
faire nation c'est prener résolument
l'humanisme et l'universalisme je ne
parle pas ici d'un universalisme dévoyé
qui voudrait masquer les singularités de
chacun dans une forme de repli
communautaire non l'universalisme dont
il est question ici c'est celui qui est
au cœur de notre pacte républicain et
qui veut respecter la diversité de
chacun car c'est bien sur l'état de
droit que repose cet universalisme en
tant qu' sent un manquement à l'égalité
les discriminations de toute nature
entam chaque jour un peu plus la
confiance dans le pacte républicain
elles sont sources de ressentiment chez
les personnes qui les subissent et
favorisent les tensions sociales surtout
quel qu'en soit le motif discriminé
c'est se privé de la diversité qui fait
la richesse d'un collectif à ce titre le
gouvernement se mobilise depuis 2017 du
plan de lutte contre contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme annoncé par Édouard
Philippe en 2018 à la mise en place de
la plateforme antidiscrimination du
Défenseur des droits vollu par le
Président de la République en 2021 nous
ne sommes pas restés
inactifs alors que plus de 7000 saisines
sont enregistré chaque année et que ce
chiffre est en constante hausse il est
bienvenu que la question de
l'identification des discrimination soit
posée à ce titre nous tenons à remercier
le rapporteur cher Marc de concrétiser
la promesse du président de la
République affirm d sa candidature en
2016 démontrer plus fidèlement
l'existence de discrimination c'est
mieux les combattre le groupe horizon ne
peut que soutenir les initiatives
permettant d'accroître la connaissance
scientifique en la matière à cet égard
le testing est un outil puissant pour
leur encore trop méconnu ou mal utilisé
il garantit une collecte de résultats
fiables prérequis plus que nécessaire à
une politique lucide d'accompagnement
des victimes de discrimination comme des
entreprises il permet d'identifier
certains a priori qui pèsent lourd dans
les décision de recrutement et
d'avancement de carrière de certaines
minorités entre autocensure et
stéréotype il est de notre devoir de
rendre plus atteignable cette promesse
d'égalité des chances que nous appelons
de nos vœux le groupe horizon et
apparenté se félicite de l'adoption de
ce texte en commission qui enrichi de
précision quant à la procédure qui incom
aux entreprise test positive donne une
base législative claire au principe dit
de name and shame pour autant endiguer
le phénomène discriminatoire ne peut pas
passer uniquement par la crédibilisation
des menaces pesant sur les entreprises
aux pratiques jugées discriminatoires
pour lutter contre ces pratiques aux
conséquences désastreuses c'est une
véritable culture de prévention et de
sensibilisation qu'il faut mettre en
place tant dans les entreprises qu'au
sein de l'administration le test
statistique est donc un prérequis pour
agir avec lucidité afin de lutter contre
les
discrimination par ailleurs nous devons
prendre garde à la lisibilité des
mesures que nous votons ici attentif à
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
surtout sur un sujet tel que celui i
nous saluons les amendements déposés en
séance visant à mettre fin au risque de
concurrence entre acteurs qui se faisait
jour en rendant expérimental la
réalisation des tests individuels cette
proposition de loi ne prétend pas régler
le problème à la racine mais elle est
une contribution nécessaire à la
résorption du phénomène
discriminatoire parce que on ne
construit pas une société sûre Pacifique
solidaire sur la haine de l'autre vous
l'aurez compris le groupe horizon et
apparenté votera en faveur de cette
proposition de
loi je vous remerci merci la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Aurélien
[Applaudissements]
tacher madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous examinons aujourd'hui
donc la proposition de loi visant à
lutter contre les discriminations par la
pratique de test individuels et
statistiqu un sujet important trop peu
discuté en tout cas rarement dans le but
d'offrir des solutions concrètes et
ambitieus les politiques publiques de
lutte contre les discriminations en
France ont un retard considérable pour
autant la France fait pourtant pourtant
pardon la France fait face à une réalité
alarmante dans ce domaine il suffit de
voir par exemple un certain nombre de
testing réalisés par des associations
comme SOS Racisme 136 agences
immobilières testé la moitié qui
acceptent ou choisissent de discriminer
des candidats au profil dit arabe ou
noir près d'un quart de ces agences qui
se rendent complices aussi en laissant
au propriétaires la possibilité de faire
ce triisriminant eux-mêm dans un pays où
se loger devient de plus en plus
difficile c'est un véritable coup de
canif à notre contrat social autre
exemple de discrimination à l'embauche
cette fois et toujours révélé par la
même association SOS Racisme 45 % des
agences d'intérim acceptent de
discriminé à la demande de clients du
BTP à nouveau cette discrimination porte
sur l'origine perçue et il en va aussi
ainsi des contrôles d'identité effectué
par la police le Défenseur des droits
nous apprend en effet qu'ils sont qu
fois plus nombreux pour des jeunes
hommes perçus comme noirs ou arabes
ainsi ces exemple de situation réelle
vécu par des millions de nos concitoyens
parfois même des collègues je veux
saluer le témoignage de Carlos Longo à
l'instant nous démontre que nous pouvons
rester indifférents finalement à cette
situation mais comment pouvons-nous
avoir une réponse à la hauteur des
enjeux lorsque nos institutions sont
aussi aveugles à l'existence et à
l'étendue du problème à mes collègues
qui réfutent les méthodes de testing
l'association cité ou qui choisissent
simplement de mettre des illerses je
veux donner un autre chiffre cette fois
du ministère de l'Intérieur en 2021 les
services de police et de gendarmerie ont
enregistré 12500 infractions à caractère
raciste xénophobe ou antireligieux soit
une hausse de 13 %. et nous le voyons
bien avec la terrible actualité de cette
dernièrees semaines nous vivons une
dramatique accélération de ces
agissements partout les actions racistes
se multiplient tac de croix gamé à Paris
où menace envoyée à une mosquée de
Valence sur les murs d'une autre mosquée
dans la Manche on a même retrouvé un bon
un tag un bon musulman et un musulman
mort c'est sûrement ce que pensait aussi
l'agresseur de Mourad ce jeune jardinier
attaqué au cuteur à villecrè de
véritables milices sortent aussi
désormais en toute impunité dans les
rues de Lyon de Bordeaux de Paris au CR
d'Islam hors d'Europe ou de français
réveille-toi tu es ici chez toi les
loups défilent à nouveau dans nos villes
parfois armée et avec la volonté de
ratonner nous l'avons bien vu la semaine
dernière à roman surizer et ce sans même
qu'éic soti interrogé par un journaliste
sur le sujet n'y trouve rien à redire
chers collègues la droite est-elle
encore réellement républicaine le
terrible meurtre du jeune Thomas en
effet immédiatement été récupéré par
l'ensemble de la droite et de l'extrême
droite comme celui de l'Ola avant lui
pour stigmatiser l'ensemble des jeunes
dont les familles sont issues de
l'immigration alors que l'enquête
désormais dément toute fable raciste
d'expédition
punitive le conflit israélo-palestinien
exacerbe aussi détenenstion alors que le
gouvernement israélien d'extrême droite
bombarde sans relâche la bande de Gaza
tu en civil et enfants par milliers tous
ceux et en particulier nos concitoyens
musulmans qui dénoncent ses crimes sont
soupçonnés de complaisance avec le Hamas
cette semaine encore Jean-Luc Mélenchon
a fait l'objet d'une cabale médiatique
pour avoir énoncer cette simple réalité
et je dis à cette tribune que je lui
apporte tout mon soutien chers collègues
vous le voyez dans ce contexte les
solutions face au racismees ne peuvent
se limiter à des approches timides il
est impératif d'adopter des mesures
ambitieuses et complètes pour remédier
aux causes profondes de de la
discrimination ne nous l'aurons pas en
effet des lois sans application et des
services sans moyens ne permettront pas
d'avancer et ce n'est pas d'un service
mais d'un ministère à part entière qui
que nous aurions besoin certes madame la
ministre vous avez cette compétence mais
avec des moyens dédiés avec des moyens
conséquents pour pouvoir vraiment
éradiquer ce fléo aujourd'hui ces moyens
sont insuffisants des réformes
institutionnelles ambitieuses s'imposent
en effet pour éliminer les structures
discriminatoires des politiques
publiques équitables guidées par des
principes antiracistes sont absolument
indispensables alors ce texte pourrait
constituer un bon point de départ
monsieur le rapporteur
je j'en conviens en créant au sein de la
dilcra une équipe chargée de réaliser
des tests collectifs pouvant donner lieu
à des poursuites pénales nous ferions un
pas dans la bonne direction mais il est
impératif que les tests individuels
restent à la main d'une autorité
indépendante celle du Défenseur des
droits il est impératif aussi que les
sanctions que nous pourrions appliquer
suite à ces tests collectifs soi plus
importante que que celle prévu
actuellement par le texte vous avez
accepté de doubler ces sanction en
commission je je le reconnais et et et
c'est une un pas dans la bonne direction
mais maintenant en cas par exemple de de
récidive que ferions-nous
accepterez-vous les amendements proposés
par les écologistes pour aller jusqu'à 5
% de la masse salariale c'est
indispensable j'ai aussi proposé que
nous puissions créer un nouveau délit
pénal pour poursuivre les chefs
d'entreprise
individuellement quand une situation de
discrimination est avérée dans le
entreprise nous regarderons
effectivement les réponses que vous
donnerez à ces différentes propositions
avant de avant de de nous prononcer sur
le vote merci à tous chers
collègues je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Frédéric
maillot
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
le texte dont nous discutons aujourd'hui
vise à lutter contre les discriminations
dans le monde du travail cette réalité
je l'ai dénoncé hier je le dénoncerai
encore demain car
malheureusement à la Réunion elle fait
partie de nos vies nous descendants
d'hommes et de femmes réduit à
l'esclavage nous descendants du Maghreb
nous descendants de colonie vous le
saviez à la Réunion il existe des pages
de Facebook de Français qui se font
appeler expatriés oui en 2023 il y a des
Français qui s'expatrient en
France pages sont le terreau de l'entre
soi de la discrimination à l'embauche
locale j'ai d'ailleurs moi-même porter
plainte c'est vous dire si la lutte
contre les discriminations est une
bataille que je mène et que je
continuerai de mener car elle existe
encore beaucoup à la Réunion je viens de
l'appir le rapport de l'Observatoire des
inégalités l'a rappelé les
discriminations s'exerce de manière
toujours plus violente brutale et
exponentielle parmi ces discriminations
les cas de discrimination en l'embauche
se font de manière toujours plus
vicieuse le rapport fait état d'un
constat sidérant un candidat au nom
français a 50 % de chance de plus d'être
raelé par un employeur par rapport à un
candidat au nom maghrébain notre
brassage à la Réunion notre brassage
ethnique et notre bâard cité fait que
certains réonnais portent fierement un
nom arabe indien chinois donc ce constat
s'applique davantage chez nous il en va
de même pour les personnes en situation
d'handicap
alors quand est-ce que la promesse
d'égalité sera tenue quand est-ce que la
promesse de fraternité sera tenue quand
est-ce que la discrimination sera
abattue si le monde du travail ne se
remplit pas encore ces promesses la
discrimination s'étend aussi à l'accès
aux soins et l'accès au logement il nous
faut alors soutenir la pertinence du
recours au testing la proposition de loi
dont nous discutons entend généraliser
ces tests de situation individuelles et
statistiqu nous ne pouvons que souscrire
à cette démarche pour lutter contre
cette injusticce il nous paraît il nous
apparît pertinent d'attribuer cette
délégation interministérielle la dilcra
la mission d'organiser et d'accompagner
la mise en œuvre de tests de masse avisé
statistique nous adhérons également nous
adhérons également au fait que ces tests
généralisés évocation à engager des
actions correctrices au sein des
organisations il s'agit là de d'une
recommandation ancienne de la Défenseur
des droits afin de sortir du recours
individuel au profit d'une approch une
approche structurelle de la lutte contre
les discriminations toutefois nous
demeurons opposés à ce que cette
nouvelle entité réalise des tests
individuels à viser contentieuse cette
mission est assurée par la Défenseur des
droits et doit le rester la doublée
rendra illisible la démarche à
l'entreprendre à à entreprendre par
toutes les victimes de discrimination
qui cherchent à être connu et rétabli
dans leur droit à moins qu'il ne s'agit
par cette disposition de remettre en
cause à terme la mission de la Défenseur
des droits ce quoi ce à quoi notre
groupe s'oppose fermement en effet en
matière de test individuel à Visé
contentieuse c'est bien la Défenseur des
droits qui est en mesure de garantir
l'indépendance et l'impartialité requise
les services de l'État ne sauraient
l'assurer dès lors qu'il pourrait faire
l'objet d'une réclamation pour
discrimination l'indépendance des
exercice et l'impartialité de jugement
nous semble être des préroquis non
négociables dès lors qu'il s'agit de
condamner des discriminations or
respecter ce préquis est le but de cette
loi d'où notre volonté de créer un
comité des parties
prenantes permettre à un représentant du
Défenseur des droits et des
organisations syndicales d'être présent
et incontournable car il est une exp
que nul ne peut égaler l'indépendance
d'exercice et l'équilibre final du
comité reste toutefois à mesuré car on
sait que c'est une que c'est un décret
qui finira leur mission à la présence de
représentants d'entreprise susceptible
d'être testé je veux partager avec vous
ces mots fondamentaux de la B piierre la
discrimination c'est comme la misère
elle ne se gère pas elle se combat je
vousci merci beaucoup le le groupe GDR
ne votera pas ce texte je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Emmanuelle
[Applaudissements]
mena madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
pour lutter contre toutes les formes de
discrimination votre proposition de loi
vise à généraliser la possibilité de
pratiquer des tests de discrimination
accompagné de la pratique du name and
shame nommé et faire honte pour les
entreprises accusées d'avoir des
pratiques discriminatoire
personnellement je préfère le recours à
la justice plutôt qu'à la dénonciation
mais vous faites surtout l'impasse sur
un élément essentiel dans la lutte
contre la discrimination j'ai nommé les
statistiques ethniques les statistiques
ethniques font régulièrement débats en
France contrairement à plus de 22 pays
en Europe ou au pays anglo-saxons comme
le Royaume-Uni ou les États-Unis où leur
utilisation est plus développée s'il
existe une interdiction de principe
inscrite à l'article 6 de la loi
Informatique et Liberté de janvier 78
qui dispose qu'il est interdit de
collecter ou de traiter des données à
caractère personnel qui font apparaître
directement ou indirectement les
origines raciales ou ethniques les
opinions politiques philosophiques ou ou
religieuse ou l'appartenance syndicale
des personnes ou qui sont relatives à la
santé ou à la vie sexuelle de cellees-ci
il n'en reste pas moins que certaines
exceptions existent au nom de la défense
de l'intérêt public ou de la protection
des personnes lever totalement
l'interdiction de la collecte de
statistiques ethniques permettrait
d'objectiver certaines données tout tout
comme cela permettrait de préciser
certaines connaissances notamment en
matière de discrimination dès lors ces
données concourrai à une meilleure
appréciation des politiques publiques
prises et apprendre les statistiques
ethniques pourraient notamment servir
les politiques d'intégration et de lutte
contre les
discriminations ainsi dans son rapport
sur l'intégration des étrangers en
France publié le 19 février 2018 le
député Aurélien Tachet qui a pris la
parole avant moi déplorait le manque de
statistiques sur les étrangers je le
cite pendant toute la durée de ma
mission je me suis hortée à la
difficulté d'objectiver nombre de
constats sur la situation des personnes
étrangères en France il proposait très
directement que les grands services
publics caisse d'Assurance Maladie
Caisse d'Allocation familial P l'emploi
et cetera puissent enrichir leurs
données de gestion par des données
objectives sur la nationalité permettant
de mesurer l'accès effectif des
étrangers à leur dispositif ces
statistiques ethniques pourraient
également être un moyen objectif et
scientifique de connaître les liens
réels entre par exemple immigration et
délinquence non pas pour stigmatisé mais
bien pour aider à mettre en place des
politiques publiques relatives à
l'intégration et à la mixité en
dévoilant officiellement ce qui est
officieusement évident depuis 40 ans le
grand secret de polychinal français le
Danemark en est d'ailleurs une parfaite
illustration la proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui se donne pour
objectif de lutter plus fermement encore
contre les discriminations puisque selon
l'exposé des motifs plus d'un quart de
la population active française considèr
que les individus sont souvent ou très
souvent discriminés au cours de leur vie
quel que soit le critère envisagé un
objectif louable naturellement qui se
donne pour levier d'action d'une part la
création d'un service placé sous la
tutelle du Premier Ministre ayant pour
mission la lutte contre toutes les
formes de discrimination et d'autre part
la création au sein de ce service d'un
comité des parties prenantes dédié à la
lutte contre les discriminations et
composé notamment de représentant des
personnes morales susceptibles d'être
testé et de parlementaires enfin la
proposition de loi donne une base
législative à la diffusion des résultats
des tests statistiques et donc à la
publication des noms des personnes
morales dont le comportement
discriminatoire serait établi deux
visions des statistiques se se dessinent
dès lors l'une pour accrocher sur le
tableau de la honte les mauvais élèves
ceux qui n'obéiraient pas à certains
critères et quotas et l'autre celle que
défend qui s'appuyant sur des données
chiffrées tenteraient de comprendre la
société dans laquelle nous vivons pour
Infiné mieux la servir convaincu que ces
données sur l'état de notre société sont
toujours bonnes à connaître j'ai déposé
un amendement pour lever totalement le
tabou des statistiques ethniques car je
le crois elles peuvent être un véritable
atout pour préciser nos connaissances
notamment en matière de discrimination
et elle concourrait certainement à une
meilleure appréciation des politiques
publique prise et à prendre dommage
qu'une fois encore il est été déclaré
irrecevable je vous remercie je vous
remercie la discussion générale est
close et donc j'appelle maintenant dans
le texte de la commission les articles
de la proposition de loi donc l'article
premier j'ai une inscrite sur l'article
madame Laurence Robert DEHA merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
une nouvelle lubi inutile rajoutant des
obligations pour les ENT prises et les
particuliers sous couvert de lutte
contre les discriminations voilà en
substance le résumé de cette initiative
de la minorité présidentielle par cette
proposition de loi le camp macroniste
admet en philigrane souscrire au thèes
de la gauche indigéniste selon laquell
les discriminations raciales en France
sont omniprésentes et structurelles
l'expérience des CV anonymes a pourtant
démontré que les personnes issues de
l'immigration avait deux fois plus de
chance d'accéder à un entretien
d'embauche avec un CV nominatif qu'avec
un CV anonyme les recruteurs ont
tendance à favoriser les dossiers de ces
personnes dans une logique de
discrimination positive pour leur
laisser leur chance mais vous continuez
dans cette logique absurde
sous-entendant que les Français seraient
racistes par essence en imaginant un
nouveau dispositif lourd coûteux et
inefficace concrètement cela va se
traduire par quoi la ministre de la
discrimination positive Beranger
Couillard a par exemple annoncé hier que
le gouvernement verrait des faux CV aux
entre prise pour les tester ou comment
faire perdre du temps et de l'argent à
tout le monde pour finir je citerai le
général de Gaul lui-même cité par son
fils dans De Gaulle mon père si une
communauté n'est pas acceptée c'est
parce qu'elle ne donne pas de bons
produits sinon elle est admise sans
problème si elle se plaint de racisme à
son égard c'est parce qu'elle est
porteuse de désordre je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame Fanta
beré
madame Fanta bérité vous avez la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues bon mon devoir c'était de
présenter l'article prier encore une
fois propos inadmissible du Front
national c'est une véritable
c'est une honte vous resterez jusquau
bout le Front national vous n'avez pas
d'idée vous n'avez rien à dire et ce que
vous venez de dire nous comparer ainsi à
des produits c'est inadmissible et
chaque jour nous serons là jusqu'en 2027
pour vous le
[Applaudissements]
rappeler donc j'en revient à l'article
1er de la proposition de loi qui est au
cœur du dispositif qui nous est proposé
par donc Marc ferrachci c'est la mise en
place d'un service gouvernemental
spécifiquement dédié à la lutte contre
toutes les formes de discrimination
origine âge adresse ou sexe par exemple
que ce soit dans l'accès à l'emploi ou
au logement des discriminations qui vont
à l'encontre de notre principe
républicain de l'égalité entre tous les
citoyens ce service sous tutelle de la
première ministre aura pour mission
principale d'aider nos concitoyens à
réaliser des test individuels à leur
demande et ce pour vérifier s'ils sont
victimes de discrimination car
aujourd'hui nous vivons où nous
entendons des témoignages sans pour
autant faire des signalements le service
pourra réaliser aussi des tests
statistiques sur des entreprises
effectivement et des organismes publics
selon des orientations définies par le
gouvernement après consultation de la
Défenseur des droits j'appelle de
manière transpartisane les unes et les
autres à soutenir cet article en
ajoutant qu'un principe transparaît
aussi dans ce texte celui de la non
discrimination ce principe est à mon
sens lié au principe constitutionnel de
la dignité qui figure à l'article 6 de
la Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen de
1789 qui impose que tous les citoyens
parce qu'ils sont égaux entre eux soient
admissibles aux dignité place et emploi
public je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
deogu
merci madame la Présidente je sais pas
dans quel monde vous vivez vous qui êtes
des élus du rassemblement national mais
on doit pas vivre dans le même monde moi
je viens des quartiers nord de Marseille
et si vous voulez voir la discrimination
vous avez qu'à venir y mettre les pieds
parce que jusqu'à présent vos propos ils
sont complètement scandaleux c'est
inadmissible d'avoir des propos pareils
dans l'hémicyclle et donc du coup si
vous avez un problème avec le racisme
structurel je vous invite de voir
le document qui a été fait par le
Défenseur des droits en 2018 et qui
justement pointe du doigt qu'il y a
effectivement du racisme culturel et
c'est de notre devoir nous députés de se
battre justement contre tous les types
de discrimination parce que quand vous
êtes effectivement un noir un arabe ou
je sais pas quelle autre origine vous
allez vous allez pouvoir
stigmatiser monsieur monsieur de Logu
s'il vous plaît allez-y continuez si
jamais si jamais madame au lieu d'être
là à toujours invectiver toujours croire
que vous avez la bonne parole vous
écoutez ces jeunes qui ne trouve pas de
travail à longueur de temps et qui
essayent d'avoir un BTS en alternance un
bac pro en alternance un stage et qui
sont dans les quartier nord de Marseille
qui ne trouvent rien parce qu'on les
stigmatise parce qu'ils sont des
maghrébains ou parce qu'ils sont noir de
peau ou parce qu'ils habitent un
quartier ou parce que je vais rajouter
quelque chose de plus personnel quand
moi j'ai travaillé à
Orange il y avait un code qui ressortait
quand il y avait un une personne qui
venait prendre un abonnement
téléphonique quand il habitait dans un
quartier il était directement remonté en
rouge parce qu'il n'avait pas le droit
de prendre d'abonnement et c'est pareil
exactement pour l'embauche madame
réfléchissez un peu et intéressez-vous à
la différence des
gens alors
nous en venons à l'amendement à
l'article et nous avons des amendements
de suppression le premier le 36 monsieur
alors allez-y monsieur le
député donc loin de nous de penser qu'il
y a pas de discrimination mais des
discriminations de toutes sortes alors
puisque monsieur puisque monsieur
bilongo a fait part de son expérience
personnelle moi il y a quelqu'un dans ma
famille qui a également qui est comme on
dit Français de souche et qui est blanc
donc et on lui a
signifié on lui a
signifié on lui a signifié on lui a
signifié parce qu'il était blanc parce
qu'il était blanc il pouvait pas
travailler dans une société de sécurité
c'est véridique voilà parce qu'il
préférait prendre des personne de
couleur donc ça existe dans tous les
sens vous racialisez les choses depuis
tout à l'heure
la discrimination touche au sexisme à la
race c'est sûr mais ça touche tout le
monde ensuite donc le gouvernement va se
lancer dans des testings à grande
échelle c'est
un cette histoire de testing ça a été
dit c'est un vieux serpent de mer
notamment de l'antiracisme il y a eu ça
a été dit les CVA anonymes par le passé
ça n'a pas marché ça a été abandonné
nous on nous on pense que ça va donner
des nouvelles contraintes des nouvelles
contraintes administratives ou autes
pour les entreprises et donc les
entreprises qui ont les moyens et ça a
été dit vont externaliser leur leur
recrutement et leur service de
ressources humaines et les petites
entreprises ne pourront pas le faire
c'est aussi un frein à la
réindustrialisation que vous voulez
faire donc ça arrive mal c'est pour ça
que pour nous l'État a mieux à faire et
que nous voulons supprimer cet article
premier alors monsieur le rapporteur
votre avis sur cet
amendement merci madame la Présidente
bien je vais pas profiter de ce premier
temps de parole pour répondre à
l'ensemble des remarques qui ont été
faites lors des discussions générales je
vais simplement rebondir sur ce qui
vient d'être dit par le rassemblement
national je suis pas très étonné
évidemment de votre propension à vouloir
supprimer cet article et se faisant
supprimer le dispositif de cette
proposition de loi votre notre carburant
politique de longue date ça n'est pas de
proposer des choses concrètes pour
améliorer la vie des Français c'est de
prospérer sur les fractur qui traverse
la société française parmi ces fractures
il y a les discriminations et cette
proposition de loi vise à lutter contre
les discriminations donc il y a une
certaine cohérence à vouloir supprimer
cet article ce que je trouve un peu
moins cohérent en revanche c'est ce que
vous dites à propos des entreprises vous
savez il y a des auditions qui sont
réalisées en amont des propositions de
loi il se trouve que nous avons
auditionné un certain nombre de
représentants des entreprises et si vous
aviez assisté à ces auditions vous
auriez entendu des représentants des
entreprises dire qu'il se satisfaisaient
d'avoir un cadre un cadre pour juger des
discriminations pour pratiquer les
testings et pour accompagner les
entreprises et ça c'est un élément qu'il
faut également avoir en tête je pense
que dans cette proposition de loi il n'y
a pas que de la sanction il y a une
logique d'accompagnement et la plupart
des discriminations que subissent les
entreprises et bien elles n'en sont pas
nécessairement consciente et elles
apprécient de pouvoir être accompagné
dans l'identification de leur processus
de recrutement lorsqu'ils donnent lieu à
des discriminations enfin vous parlez et
là aussi vous auriez gagné à participer
aux auditions de l'externalisation
sachez que certaines entreprises
externalisent déjà leur processus de
recrutement sachez que on peut faire des
testings sur les prestataires et sachez
que dans les contrats qui lient les
entreprises à ces prestataires qui font
des recrutements pour elle certaines
entreprises introduisent des clauses
pour éviter justement les
discriminations ça signifie que si on
teste les prestataires externes et bien
on atteint l'objectif que l'on poursuit
donc ne caricaturez pas ce que sont les
positions des entreprise je pense que
vous les avez beaucoup caricaturé dans
les propos de la dire de la déclaration
générale et dans vos propos globalement
il y a beaucoup de choses fausses qui
sont ditite ce sera un avis défavorable
sur cet amendement je vous remercie
madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci madame la
Présidente je tenais à dire au députés
du rassemblement national que je suis
totalement affligé en fait par les
propos que vous avez tenu depuis le
début de de ces
discussions dire que vous avez
totalement focalisé notamment sur les
discriminations liées à l'origine à la
couleur de peau vous avez totalement
focalisé parce que il n'y a que ça en
fait qui fait
aujourd'hui votre votre motivation alors
que vous avez totalement écarté vous
avez totalement écarté les
discriminations liées à l'âge au sexe
qui ont été d'ailleurs rappelés durant
les la discussion générale également lié
au handicap lié également à
l'orientation sexuelle vous avez évoqué
aussi un certain nombre de
discriminations je vous rappelle qu'il y
en a 25 qui aujourd'hui sont reconnus
dans la loi donc je ne comprends pas
votre obstination à aller sur ce type de
discrimination uniquement celle-ci en
tout cas et retirer donc l'amendement le
premier amendement faire en sorte qu'il
tombe remettrait totalement en cause ce
que nous sommes en train de faire avec
monsieur le rapporteur et donc
évidemment c'est un avis
défavorable je vous remercie monsieur BL
vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre je vais tenter de de
répondre et remettre un petit peu
l'église au milieu du village nous avons
dit durant la discussion générale nous
avons dit durant la discussion générale
effectivement que nous combattons et
nous lutons pardon contre toutes les
discriminations quel qu'ell soit quel
qu'ell soit nous reconnaissons une seule
communauté la communauté nationale alors
n mélangeons pas tout ici premièrement
qu'est-ce que nous disons par rapport à
ce texte qu'est-ce que nous disons nous
disons simplement que on va créer un
nouveau comité Théodule une nouvelle
charge pour les entreprises alors qu'en
fait il suffirait d'avoir une politique
globale d'un point de vue pénal
d'augmenter peut-être les peines je
dirais d'articuler tout ça autour des
poursuites judiciaires et surtout
d'envoyer il faut le dire les gens en
prison ce que vous ne faites pas depuis
que vous êtes au gouvernement 41 % des
gens qui ont une peine de prison ne
passent pas une seule nuit en prison
c'est tout ce que nous disons donc ce
comité Théodule rime en vérité avec nul
c'est nul vraiment c'est mal ficelé et
euh nous voterons évidemment pour cette
suppression nous la proposons et
arrêterz euh dans ces débats de de de
considérer le RN comme votre paillasson
parce que je pense effectivement que
nous avons l'avantage par rapport à vous
de défendre les Français de manière
claire je le répète nous défendons une
seule communauté la communauté nationale
je vous
remercie monsieur Armand vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
écoutez on savait que cette proposition
de loi de notre collègue Marc Ferrach
était nécessaire et était utile face aux
discriminations nombreuses que vivent
les salariés en France et qui sont
inacceptables on découvre aussi qu'elle
est nécessaire avec ces amendements de
suppression ces justifications confuses
du rassemblement national c'est aussi
une vaste opération T pour le
rassemblement national en quelques
instants en quelques instants mon cher
collègue vous avez parlé en quelques
instant mon cher collègue vous avez
parlé de race ça n'existe pas la science
le dém en quelques instants vous avez
parlé des Français de souche quels
sont-ils les Français de souche vous
allez peut-être nous dire ce que c'est
qu'un Français de souche est-ce que moi
Petitfils d'immigré je suis un Français
de souche parce que je suis blanc est-ce
que mes collègues parce qu'ils n'ont pas
la mme couleur de peau mais qu'ils sont
nés en France et ont des grands-parents
français sont des Français de souche
expliquez-nous révélez-vous c'est aussi
pour vous une opération de
testing je vous remercie donc je vais
mettre au voix cet amendement qui a un
double avis défavorable qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
nous en arrivons au 45 monsieur tachi
vous avez la parole oui merci madame la
Présidente bon cet amendement il vise à
à à renforcer le rôle du Défenseur des
droits dans le dispositif qui va être
qui est proposé aujourd'hui monsieur le
rapporteur j'ai envie de vous dire
aidez-nous à vous aider quand on entend
effectivement les sorties depuis à peine
un quart d'heure que ce débat a commencé
du rassemblement national sur
effectivement les Français de souche sur
la race sur un espèce de racisme
antiblanc complètement fantasmé monsieur
vous dites ce que vous racontez est
totalement faux personne dans ce pays
n'a jamais été discriminé dans son accès
à l'emploi dans son accès au logement
dans son accès à quoi que ce soit parce
qu'il était blanc vous êtes un menteur
vous êtes un menteur et en réalité tout
le reste de votre discours démontre en
fait l'importance que vous que vous
accordez à la promesse républicaine et à
cette cause de l'antiracisme vous nous
expliquez que ce serait un frein à la
réindustrialisation ce serait trop de
contraintte administrativ votre collègue
nous parle de comité Théodule on parle
de racisme on parle de gens qui sont
discriminés qui perdent des emplois des
logements on parle de la promesse
républicaine ça doit être pris avec un
tout petit peu plus de sérieux donc je
le redis à monsieur le rapporteur la
gauche a envie de le soutenir sur ce
texte il faut respecter le rôle du
Défenseur des droits et faisons front
ensemble quand on entend ce genre de
d'infamille là qui ont commencé depuis
seulement 10 minutes au bout de ce débat
je crois véritablement qu'il faut tous
qu'on fasse à pas vers l'autre pour
avancer sur un texte ambitieux merci